S
OR DO HIS THE WAY HE DOES MINE,
TRUST ME.
HERE WITH REACTION, THE AUTHOR
OF THE UPCOMING BOOK FOR SUCH A
TIME AS THIS, MY FAITH JOURNEY
THROUGH THE WHITE HOUSE AND
BEYOND, "OUTNUMBERED" COHOST
KAYLEIGH McENANY AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR ARI FLEISCHER.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE IS A
LOT OF PROJECTION IN THIS WORLD.
>> WHAT A MEMORY LANE YOU JUST
WALK DOWN, POISON INJECT INTO
THE AMERICAN BODY OF POLITICS BY
CNN.
YOU HUMOROUSLY CALLED JOE BIDEN
THE SIPPY CUP PRESIDENT.
WHAT DID CNN DO TO THE NATION BY
TELLING EVERYBODY ALL THE TIME
THAT THE 2015 ELECTION WAS
ILLEGITIMATELY WON BY
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE HE COLLUDED
WITH RUSSIA AS A RESULT OF THE
ELECTION AND FOR FOUR STRAIGHT
YEARS QUESTIONING THE
PRESIDENT'S LEGITIMACY AND AS
YOU POINT OUT, HITLER AND
MUSSOLINI AND ALL THE OTHER
REFERENCES TO FASCISM AND THEN
CNN SAYS IT'S THE OTHER GUY?
IT JUST CAN'T WORK THAT WAY SO
GOOD FOR YOU, YOU BLEW A WHISTLE
AND I GUESS CNN DOESN'T WANT TO
HEAR IT.
>> Sean: CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR BOOK, LOOKING FORWARD TO
READING IT WHEN IT COMES OUT.
I'D LIKE TO SAY, AND I SAY THIS
OFTEN.
I'M A MEMBER OF THE PRESS, I AM
A TALK SHOW HOST.
WHAT IS A TALK SHOW HOST?
I CAN PRODUCE THOUSANDS OF HOURS
OF STRAIGHT NEWS COVERAGE ON
RADIO AND TV, THOUSANDS OF HOURS
OF INVESTIGATIVE REPORTING THAT
OTHERS DO NOT, WE TALK ABOUT
CULTURE, SPORTS AND YES, I GIVE
MY OPINION AND I DON'T HIDE THE
FACT THAT I AM IN A LOUD, PROUD,
UNAPOLOGETIC CONSERVATIVE.
I'M LIKE A WHOLE NEWSPAPER.
THEY SAY THEY ARE JOURNALISTS,
THEY ARE NOT, THAT'S A LIE.
>> YOU'VE DONE MORE JOURNALISM
THAN ANY ONE OF THEM.
I'VE WATCHED YOU UNRAVEL THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION CONSPIRACY
THEORY WEEK BY WEEK AND
MEANWHILE, I'M A LITTLE WORRIED
FOR YOU, A LITTLE FATAL
ATTRACTION VIBE AS I WAS
WATCHING THOSE CLIPS FROM BRIAN
STELTER.
HE DOES NOT HAVE RELIABLE
SOURCES BUT HE DOES RELIABLY
STOCK YOU.
HE ASKED JEN PSAKI WHAT IS THE
PRESS GETTING WRONG?
HE IS FAWNING OVER JOE BIDEN,
AND THEN HE BROADCASTS IN HIS
BOXERS AND IT APPEARS MANY CNN
HAVE A PROCLIVITY BROADCASTING
HALF CLOTHED, BOTH HIM AND
JEFFREY TOOBIN, HAD A LOT OF
ISSUES, NO WONDER THE DECLINING
VIEWERSHIP.
>> Sean: WHY DID YOU HAVE TO
BRING UP JEFFREY TOOBIN?
VERY BAD MEMORIES FOR ANYONE WHO
HAS A SOUL AND A CONSCIENCE.
THE THING THAT I FIND MOST
INTERESTING AND I JUST DON'T
CARE WHAT OTHER PEOPLE SAY.
WHATEVER SWITCH I'M SUPPOSED TO
HAVE THAT CARES ABOUT WHAT OTHER
PEOPLE THINK OF ME, IT DOESN'T
EXIST.
THEY SEEM TO BE SO
HYPERSENSITIVE IN THEIR LITTLE
BLUE CHECK BUBBLE WORLD THAT
THEY LIVE IN THAT THEY CAN'T
TAKE THE CRITICISM THAT THEY
RIGHTLY DESERVE, NO OR THAT THEY
ARE BIASED.
>> I USED TO BE A CNN
CONTRIBUTOR, SPENT TWO YEARS
THEY ARE AND HAVE TO SAY IT WAS
UNDER A DIFFERENT PRESIDENT, NOT
UNDER THE CURRENT PRESIDENT.
IT WAS A VERY DIFFERENT
NEWSGATHERING ORGANIZATION AND
RIGHT NOW, THE DIRECTION OF
FLOWS FROM THE TOP AND THEN TOP
IS TO PLAY TO THE LEFT, USE THE
WORDS THAT DIVIDE THE COUNTRY
AND GO AFTER FOX.
I'M WRITING A BOOK ABOUT THE
MEDIA CALLED "BROKEN" AND CNN
WILL HAVE ITS OWN CHAPTER IN IT.
CNN PUT MICHAEL AVENATTI ON THE
AIR 254 TIMES IN THE SPACE OF
LESS THAN ONE YEAR.
MICHAEL AVENATTI BECAME A CNN GO
TO PERSON.
THAT TELLS YOU HOW WRONG THEIR
JUDGMENT IS COMING INTO THIS.
TALK ABOUT POISON AND BAD WORDS.
BREONNA TAYLOR TWO WEEKS AGO,
ONE OF THEIR FINGERS CALLED
RAND PAUL ON THE AIR.
I DON'T REMEMBER BRIAN STETLER
TELLING HER SHE SHOULDN'T TALK
LIKE THAT AND THAT THAT'S WRONG
AND THEN BRIAN AND HIS MONOLOGUE
ACCUSED YOU OF ENCOURAGING
PEOPLE FOR VIOLENCE.
WHAT ABOUT CHRIS CUOMO WHO AT
THE HEIGHT OF THE GEORGE FLOYD
PROTEST WHEN CITIES WERE UNDER
CURFEW ACROSS AMERICA SAID I
DON'T REMEMBER SEEING ANYWHERE
THAT IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
PEACEFUL.
WHERE WAS TH